die Ampel steht
was bedeutet das konkret
178 Seiten anderes Vertrag der
Deutschland Plan für die nächsten vier
Jahre also und das ist viel Stoffe sehr
viel Stoff um alles genau durchzulesen
Wort für Wort und er hat's getan unser
Bild Parlament Chef Ralf Schuler Ralf
schön dass du da bist hallo ja und diese
fünf kleinen Dinge haben dich besonders
groß aufgeregt wie diese Passage z.b. im
Koalitionsvertrag zum Ausländerrecht
nämlich da heißt es wir werden die
Klärung der Identität eine Ausländerin
oder eines Ausländers um die Möglichkeit
eine Versicherung an Eides statt
abzugeben erweitern und werden hierzu
eine gesetzliche Regelung im
Ausländerrecht schaffen Ralf Schuler das
muss man sich mal klarmachen es war
eines der größten Probleme in der
migrationskrise 2015 dass wir keine
Identitäten hatten von den Zugewanderten
die sie einfach weggeworfen hatten um
bestimmte Länder als Herkunftsländer
beispielsweise oder ein alter anzugeben
und die Kollektion macht sich die Welt
wie Sie sie gerne haben möchte und sagt
gut kann man künftig auch einfach
unterschreiben ich bin der und der und
ich bin so und so alt in Verbindung mit
dem neuen Zuwanderungsrecht was sie auch
einführen wollen wäre es naheliegend
dass man sich einen möglichst junges
Alter gibt weil man ab 27 dann wenn man
drei Jahre in Deutschland gewesen ist
schon ein unbegrenztes Aufenthaltsrecht
bekommt also da schneidet sich die neue
Koalition wirklich irgendwie ins eigene
Fleisch
die Ampel steht
ja selbst übers Thema Verhütung haben
sich Scholz Lindner Habeck und baerbock
ihre Gedanken gemacht für mich im
Koalitionsvertrag wir wollen
Krankenkassen ermöglichen
Verhütungsmittel als Satzungsleistung zu
erstatten bei gering verdienenden werden
die Kosten übernehmen über normal so der
Staat zahlt Kondome gratis Gummis ist
immer eine gute Sache es gab ja schon
den Vorstoß die Mehrwertsteuer von 19
auf 7 % zu senken bei Hygieneartikeln
jetzt also der weitere Vorstoß auch die
männliche Verhütung ins Visier zu nehmen
hochinteressant ich bin gespannt welche
Kondome da erstattet werden ob alle
bunten alle gerippten gehen rot zwischen
und mit welchen Geschmackssorten das ist
hochinteressant im Ernst es geht
natürlich darum dass Verhütung keine
Sache der Frauen ist das kann man ja
nachvollziehen und deshalb sollen bei
sozialen schwachen auch die Kondome
künftig erstattungsfähig sind ob das
wirklich funktioniert ist eine andere
Sache das andere ist natürlich
eine seltsame Schwerpunktsetzung auf
solchen Detail Fragen in einem
Koalitionsvertrag der Deutschland die
nächsten Jahre prägen soll also da ist
irgend mit irgendjemand ist dann das
Pferd durchgegangen das Scholz Kondom
Tollwitz die Ampel steht
noch besser
Gemeinschaft ich bin gespannt wie das
wird wenn irgendjemand aus dem Nahen
Osten mit mehreren Frauen einreißt und
die Vielehe war bisher in Deutschland
nicht gestattet das wird jetzt eine
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft kann man
gerne so machen aber es war bislang in
unserem Kulturkreis eigentlich nicht
üblich was dahinter steckt ernsthaft
gesehen ist dass man versuchen will die
Partnerschaften von Homosexuellen die
gemeinsame Kinder haben irgendwie
zusammenzubinden und in einer
Gemeinschaft Verbindung zu bringen man
öffnet damit aber natürlich Anna bunten
Personengesellschaft Tür und Tor und
eigentlich ist dafür er das
Firmenrechtsschutz ständig die
Gesellschaft mit beschränkter Haftung
die Ampel steht und
auch das hier will die Ampel Regeln
große Worte beim Thema Frauenrechte wenn
ich diese gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern
wollen wir im Sinne einer feminist
foreign policy Rechte Ressourcen und
Repräsentanz von Frauen und Mädchen
weltweit stärken und gesellschaftliche
Diversität fördern das klingt wie
Vereinte Nationen Ralf das sind
interessanter. Weil auch hier plötzlich
dieser seltsame Wechsel ins Englische
erfolgt das ist nicht ganz ohne
Hintergrund die FDP hat sich maßgeblich
dagegen gesträubt dass man feministische
Außenpolitik schreibt also haben die
Grünen den man das Feld der
Gesellschaftspolitik weitgehend
überlassen hat hier das eng den
englischen Begriff gewählt man darf
gespannt sein ob Außenpolitik
funktioniert indem wir Ihnen unsere
Werte in alle Welt tragen und den
Menschen in Afrika oder einen anderen
Ländern
mitgeben wie sie mit ihren
gesellschaftspolitischen Werten
umzugehen haben das wird ein hartes Brot
für die Außenministerin wenn sie es denn
an Alina Bär werden sollte einmal nur
viel Erfolg wünschen